[Musique]
salut à tous on peut souvent lire
l'histoire d'un pays à travers sa
géographie tel frontières issues de
telles victoires tel autre de telles
défaites aux usa comme ailleurs les
frontières sont aussi tributaires de
l'histoire et elles ont aussi en partie
a été tracé autour de la question
esclavagiste si bien que les cartes
américaines portent aujourd'hui encore
les traces de l'histoire de l'esclavagé
je vous propose donc de découvrir cette
histoire à travers entre autres la
géographie esclavage a cours en amérique
du nord depuis la fondation des colonies
britanniques au début du xviie siècle
et dès les premières années des esclaves
africains sont amenés pour travailler
dans les plantations de tabac
dès cette époque les noirs représentent
aux alentours de 10% de la population et
grimperont jusqu'à 20% à la veille de la
révolution avec une forte concentration
dans le vieux sud l'amérique blanche est
un mythe
mais avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet
quelques mots sur les cultures
régionales en amérique anglaise pour
comprendre le clivage nord-sud
historiquement on peut diviser les
colonies anglaises en deux grands blocs
culturel au nord on a affaire à des
colonies de peuplement économiquement
basée sur un modèle agricole familial
puis à partir du 19ème siècle sur
l'industrie ces colonies ont été créées
par des minorités religieuses
chrétiennes fuyant les guerres et
persécutions du vieux continent
la question de l'éthique chrétienne il
ya très forte notamment en nouvelle
angleterre bastion du puritanisme et en
pennsylvanie
cette région ne comporte que 2 à 3%
d'esclaves le sud lui est constitué de
colonies d'exploitations agricoles dont
les produits sont destinés à
l'angleterre puis à l'exportation avec
des plantations demandant une importante
main d'oeuvre servile on y cultive le
tabac le riz à cannes à sucre et surtout
à partir du 19ème siècle le coton
indispensables à l'industrie textile
naissante qui fera la richesse de la
région
les noirs et représente 40% de la
population lors de l'indépendance et un
tiers à la veille de la guerre de
sécession l'esclavagé n'a donc pas la
même importance au nord qu'au sud le
nord peut très bien s'en passer
alors que le sud en dépend
structurellement dès le début des années
1700 les idées abolitionniste voit le
jour au nord et des associations sont
créés dans la seconde moitié du xviiie
siècle
mais l'occasion de mettre réellement la
question en débat et la garde
pendant ce thomas jefferson le principal
rédacteur de la déclaration
d'indépendance prépare une première
mouture du texte condamnant la traite
humaine mouture rejetée par les
représentants des états du sud
voulant préserver l'unité des ex
colonies les abolitionnistes reculent
temporairement l'esclavagé relève du
choix de chaque état fédéré et les
etats-unis né s'en vont donc devoir
tolérer ce qu'on appelle alors arfelis
mme l'institution particulière néanmoins
si l'abolition pure et simple n'est pas
à l'ordre du jour la cause
abolitionniste triomphe dans de nombreux
états du nord qui interdisent
l'institution particulière rapidement
après l'indépendance au point qu'un
équilibre numérique se crée entre états
libres et esclavagiste avec
l'indépendance
la question de l' esclavage se pose
aussi sous une nouvelle forme alors que
la couronne britannique préféré la
stabilité de ses frontières et avait
signé des accords de non expansion avec
les amérindiens au grand mécontentement
des colons américains l'indépendance
marque aussi le début de la conquête de
l'ouest
tout au long du xixème siècle de
nouvelles terres sont annexés de gré ou
de force aux usa colonisés et de nouveau
et à créer ces deux nouveaux états
peuvent-ils autoriser ou non l'esclavagé
autoriser ou non modifiera le rapport de
forces au niveau fédéral en 1787 des
ordonnances du nord-ouest car portant
sur les nouveaux territoires de cette
zone codifie la colonisation
elle crée notamment la notion de
territoire zones annexées aux états unis
est directement gérée par l'état fédéral
en attendant que des états fédérés ci
crée elles définissent le mode
d'adhésion des nouveaux territoires aux
usa et enfin à bord de la question de l'
esclavage qui sera interdit au nord de
la rivière ohio
cette méthode de législation territoire
par territoire sera ensuite reprise tout
au long de la conquête de l'ouest
les etats unis font donc le choix
d'entériner la fracture qui apparaît sur
la question maintenir le nord libre et
le sud esclavagiste
ce statu quo a duré plusieurs décennies
mais va poser encore une nouvelle
question que faire des noirs libres car
si l'amérique blanche est un mythe
l'idée de construire une amérique
blanche est ancien l'abolitionnisme
n'est pas forcément synonyme de volonté
d'égalité politique pour de nombreux
nordistes
anwar libre d'accord mais noir citoyens
hors de question
ainsi l'état de l'illinois par exemple
interdit l'installation sur son
territoire des noirs libres pour
résoudre la question noire de bons
citoyens surtout esclavagistes ont créé
la société de colonisation américaine en
1817 la société achète des terres en
afrique et fonde le liberia espérant y
attirer les noirs libres quelques
milliers d'affranchis iront s'installer
leur libération est temps parfois
conditionnée à cet exil les descendants
d'affranchis vous former une élite
locale et dominer la vie politique du
pays pendant un siècle et demi jusqu'à
un coup d'état des autochtones
le liberia est d'ailleurs implanté à
côté de la sierra leone un territoire
achetés par les anglais pour y implanter
les esclaves ayant combattu à ses côtés
contre l'indépendance américaine
pour en revenir aux états unis la
demande d'adhésion du missouri dans les
années 1810 en tant qu'etat dans l'union
va faire ressurgir au niveau fédéral la
question de la répartition géographique
de l'escale âge le missouri est alors
peuplé de colomb venant d'états
esclavagiste voisins et naturellement
ils veulent faire du nouvel état un état
esclavagiste pour y reproduire
l'économie de plantation cotonnière qui
à l'époque est extrêmement lucrative le
territoire du missouri n'étant pas dans
la zone d'application de l'ordonnancé du
nord-ouest en théorie c'est possible
mais l'admission dans l'union en tant
qu'etat esclavagiste ferait basculer
l'équilibré national en faveur de ces
derniers de vifs débats ont lieu au
sénat et on trouve finalement un
compromis purement arithmétique le
missouri est admis comme états
esclavagistes
mais dans le même temps le maine qui est
un état libre est aussi incorporé comme
ça le rapport de forces est conservé
avec douze états de chaque côté en
parallèle pour que la question ne se
reposent plus à chaque demande
d'adhésion pour limiter l'expansion de
l' esclavage et qu'ils ne gagnent pas le
nord on décide que les nouveaux états ne
pourront être esclavagiste que s'il se
situe en dessous de la frontière sud du
missouri
ce compromis un compromis du missouri
adopté en mdc cciq 6820 sera respectée
pendant trois décennies
lors de la conquête de l'ouest les
trente années suivantes ont donc être
calme sur la question au niveau de la
politique institutionnelle mais la
société civile elle va évoluer
l'anti esclavagisme va muter jusque-là
gradualiste voulant l'extinction
progressive de l'institution
particulière notamment en interdisant
l'importation d'esclaves
une partie va se radicaliser et devenir
immédiate east le sud lui prend
conscience de son particularisme et des
arguments théoriques presque lavage vont
émerger le principal théoricien de l'
esclavage et john calhoun un homme
politique sud caroline yankee sera nam
vice président des états unis
calhoun et racistes au sens premier du
terme il pense qu'il existe une
hiérarchie des races les blancs dominant
les noirs le propriétaire sudiste est un
aristocrate une race supérieure qui
domine les noirs naturellement inférieur
dans cette logique
l'esclavagé est nécessaire mais en plus
souhaitable car il respecte cette
hiérarchie des races calhoun a aussi
théorisé l'annuler fication à savoir le
non respect des lois fédérales si elles
nuisent aux états à travers la nuit
fication c'est la question de la nature
des états unis qui est posée sont ils
une fédération ou une confédération
les états sont ils les sous partie d'un
tout indivisible ou bien les briques de
base de l'union pouvant se des fédérés à
loisir pour le sud
les usa sont une confédération et si le
niveau fédéral ne respecte pas les
particularismes locaux
les états peuvent se des fédérés calhoun
par cette théorie ouvre la voie à la
sécession d'ailleurs à ce n'est pas un
hasard si pendant la guerre de sécession
les états du sud prendront le nom de
confédération des états d'amérique
à côté de cela tout au long de la
première moitié du 19e siècle le sud on
durcit le contrôle des esclaves tout
cela fait que l'esclavagé n'est plus
seulement à ressorts économiques
c'est un mode de vie qui fait la
spécificité culturelle des élites et du
sud c'est le monde de fantasmes et
d'autant en emporte le vent
d'un point de vue historique on parle de
sectionner l'isthme pour désigner le
fossé politique et culturelle de plus en
plus grand entre le nord et le sud
maintenant revenons à notre géographie
de l' esclavage en 1849 1850 le
compromis du missouri va prendre
quelques coups de canif à cause de la
guerre d'expansion contre le mexique
les territoires pris aux mexicains
peuvent-ils être esclavagiste le débat
au sénat d'un lieu au compromis de 1850
la californie est déclarée état libre
mais dans le nouveau-mexique et l'ugta
et alors que ce dernier se trouve
pourtant au dessus de la frontière sud
du missouri
c'est le principe de souveraineté
populaire qui s'appliquera les habitants
devant décider eux mêmes s'ils tolèrent
l'esclavagé
également les esclaves en fuite peuvent
désormais être arrêté au nord qui n'est
plus un sanctuaire pour eux en 1854
nouveau coup de canif des états se crée
au nord-ouest mais il reste un
territoire non organisé entre eux et les
états de l'est pour se développer
ces états ont besoin du chemin de fer
qui devrait passer par cet espace des
sénateurs nordistes veulent donc créer
deux états le nebraska et le kansas pour
donner un statut clair à ses terres et y
faire passer leur chemin de fer sans
encombre pour cela ils ont besoin du
vote des élus du sud est vont donc leur
faire des concessions notamment le
principe de souveraineté populaire sur
la question de l' esclavage pour ces
deux nouveaux états à cause de cela la
création du kansas déclenchera une
course à la colonisation des nordistes
pro abolition y venant en masse
espérant faire basculer l'état dans le
camp des états libres une fois sa
constitution rédigée il y aura des
violences et des bourrages d'urnes et
pendant la guerre de sécession le kansas
très divisés politiquement verra
apparaître des guérillas paramilitaires
et trois ans plus tard en 1857 le
principe même du compromis du missouri
est remis en cause de façon rétroactive
par la cour suprême dans son arrêt dred
scott dred scott était un esclave vivant
dans le missouri
mais ayant suivi son propriétaire dans
ses déplacements à travers le pays ayant
donc résider dans des états interdisant
les scribes âge scott demandé à être
reconnue comme libre
le procès va arriver jusqu'à la cour
suprême qui va dire plusieurs choses
un noirs esclaves ne devient pas libre
en vivant dans un état d'un esclavagiste
même libre un noir n'est pas citoyen des
etats-unis donc ne peut pas saisir la
justice et surtout la cour va plus loin
que la question posée et d'éclairs le
compromis du missouri un constitutionnel
estimant que l'état fédéral n'avait pas
à interdire l'esclave âge dans certains
états fédérés car l'esclave est une
propriété et que le droit de propriété
est garantie par le cinquième amendement
précisons que la cour suprême est
constitué de neuf juges et au moment de
statuer sur l'affairé de scott
elle est constituée de cinq sudiste et
quatre nordistes s'est arrêté a été
approuvée à 7 contre 2 signe que même au
nord la question fait débat
cet arrêt est le coup fatal porté au
compromis du missouri
il n'y a plus de limites géographiques
théorique à l'expansion de l' esclavage
dont l'adoption ou le refus repose
uniquement sur la seule volonté des
états fédérés à la veille de la guerre
de sécession toutes les barrières
institutionnelles construite par les
abolitionnistes pour tenter d'endiguer
les esclavages à défaut de pouvoir
l'abolir ont cédé même si les états
libres sont majoritaires et tensions
entre pro et anti esclavage pour
atteindre leur paroxysme en 1860 lors de
la présidentielle très disputé puisque
quatre candidats s'affrontent alors
c'est un peu par hasard que lincoln le
candidat du jeune parti républicain anti
esclavagiste l'emportent élections qui
débouchera sur la sécession du sud
et sans la guerre civile qui ont des
couleurs il est probable que
l'institution particulière aurait encore
perdurer de nombreuses décennies voire
se sera étendu en tout cas voilà pour
l'histoire de l'esclavagé aux états unis
j'espère que cette vidéo parfois un
petit peu dessous des cartes vous aura
plu si c'est le cas et bien n'hésitez
pas à la partager
moi je donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine vidéo d'ici là je vous dis
portez vous bien et à la prochaine
[Musique]